hello welcome to the lobby filthy casual
edition number one of maybe four before
we get the new show set up sounds about
right Eric k what up you know you're
part of the new Lobby production crew
yeah Higgins 44 of it yeah you got for
that will have just shot back hopefully
on the editing on the production side
next week he's at CES Andy baman here
running around with his own of the
camera set up making it look good he's
come over and II of the point fame it's
gonna be director of photography on this
new lobby we're redoing the lobby we're
kind of tearing it down and building it
back up again because that's basically
happened to our set yeah it's like we
move floors we come from 3rd floor first
floor and we still need that sick game
spot Talent which my mic my heart is
here what's up hey you doing buddy I'm
not on the lobby production staff but
i'll probably be here once in a while to
sound like a kind of know what I'm that
we play those video games you played
that ex-con we're gonna get to that in a
little bit I played a lot of exes you've
got all the ex-con knowledge got the
swap a dandy for that boy stay don't
know a goddamn thing about XCOM and then
I'm gonna take her baby yeah you just
seeing could just sip on your [ __ ]
bungee tea bag it's not like a new
year's resolution something new you know
I'm actually just biting cold so oh is
that what it is nice to have some tea
here good nice to know I you were sick
before I put you in this incubator with
me and my hardon five days deep man
we're good i keeps it for friday is
there like a rule five days it's passed
the examination period until five days
ago to the doctor I thought five days
was like when you're the most contagious
dude I'm right next time i had like
wicked bad constipation over christmas
like real bad like I didn't poop in like
three days and I book like three days a
day pooping in today I know I'm so I'm
especially for Christmas when literally
all I'm doing is sitting down playing
video games and eating sounds like a
fiber issue it was so I went out but
then what happened was I think I ate too
much fiber cuz then suddenly all I was
eating was fiber celery in celery this
is vibrant celery okay yeah there's old
fruit basically like fiber bars Nana's
fiber supplements I don't know what a
nanner is what's that banana
banana nanners that words not
complicated enough you're gonna make up
with more complicated version that's a
bananas way to say that there you go
Jesus that's why we brought you in yeah
but we're redoing the lobby and we're
kind of figure internet we've already
had a couple meetings went back to our
constituencies over over the holidays
and kind of thought about it and and I
feel like we have one of these meetings
where we kind of total down and then
figured out like what's the best way to
do this what's the best way to use the
set what's the what's one of the ways in
which the show works and what are ways
in which the show sucks and I guess we
kind of have this like formula now where
we're basically just making like
breakouts from the titles like we the
whole show is based around like titles
right yeah of course I mean it's the
most interesting things right like
that's what that's what's gonna draw
people in um bad in the thumbnails would
you make Thank You Danny but it's not
and that's kind of like the way that's
the reason it sucks as well is because
we have this show is basically all right
how can we get people to watch a 10
minute video bet XCOM so we'll say like
this week's one is gonna be called
friggin like is the X is XCOM 2 to
casual like yeah spoiler it's not right
not at no no it's not at all but it gets
people to watch it great title right
yeah but that's what the lobby just
ended up only being was like oh it's
just like not not super baby but like us
like setting up sections to get people
to watch them and it it almost might as
well not have been a live show yeah I
mean it's hard right like I think the
live show we did those segments and like
we kind of had them planned out or like
you know collectively would would figure
it out and plan it out and it kind of
worked for live which was the nice part
but like in a way we were kind of like V
OD'ing it you know like you're making
them kind of like okay we this is what
its gonna be and this is kind of why
we're doing it like super efficient way
of creating a bunch of like on demand
videos for the site in YouTube but
wasn't really a good live experience
what if why would you watch the lobby
live I was coming for a while I was kind
of thinking like oh like we'd basically
didn't know feedback at all with there
was no like spontaneity at all cuz we
planned everything so well it was almost
like to well planned yeah I mean like
the only segments that kind of kind of
got the community involved were you know
the Aster reviewer segments were your
kind of like field questions or kind of
looking comments and whatnot maybe that
wasn't
live as we could be but like that will
at least kind of brought that up and
it's something we're looking into right
like that's part of like the like
initiative for this year is kind of like
how do we kind of bring the community
into it how do we make it more of a live
show so that you know like it is a live
thing and not just servicing a VOD thing
I mean like we're still gonna have
segments our bread and butter we gotta
do it we get that traffic like that's
like that's what keeps took people seem
to like them as well they've actually
done really well over the last year it's
definitely better than the previous year
complains it shows been running for two
years crazy yeah but yeah when I look at
like the stuff that's come out of those
meetings it's it's like pretty exciting
like we're going to keep we're gonna
have like a way more better structured
kind of lobby show still tuesdays at 2pm
looks like but we're going to keep going
once the show kind of finishes we're
going to like do a sort of open play
we're gonna start playing more games
during like it'll basically like soft
finish yeah and then we'll keep laying
for maybe an hour or two and get people
involved and then on friday we're doing
this like lunched well this is like the
current plan we're basically gonna do
like a two to three-hour live show for
only the community so feedback on all
gamespot stuff youtube reviews like all
the stuff we don't cover on the show
that we wouldn't because like this is
too like much of a news show but there's
so much other [ __ ] happening in like the
wider gaming community that like like
trends in our headlines that we can kind
of talk about their like really get into
a get a bunch of guests in we're like
looking at like skyping people in like
our industry folks we can kind of act as
a conduit between gamers and those folks
instead of us being like i don't know it
feels like being in the games price
getting weirder and weirder like 2016
it's like games coverage isn't what that
is anymore especially for us in video
because it's like video has gone off in
its completely other direction so we've
kind of had to re-evaluate it like the
way we relate to everyone especially our
audience so def right is your I'm super
excited about because that's basically
like our like community blowout and
we're going to do some [ __ ] really
fun stuff on that and I think hopefully
for the community to you know like we
can get guests like Mike on we got some
other people on just to kind of talk
about stuff that's happening during the
week and then kind of go back and forth
a little bit with the community which
yes I think we
haven't really been able to do or we
just like this is going to be our way to
try to figure that out I guess a little
bit or just kind of start to get that
involvement start to build that up and
and you know hopefully it's fun for them
too well I'm really excited to see kind
of just how where that goes yes it's
something we haven't done for a while
and I know that you know there are like
super fans and fans that you know they
want to talk to like you Andy my other
editors as well like Alexa Scott etc and
this will kind of give a spot for that
yes and actually get responses like I
don't think it's something we're all
trying to do better I think this year
like you know just get back to the
community because we don't do a good job
we always say like hey watch this video
and then give us your comments below
yeah oh yeah I'm real guilty at I like
every episode 1 on the lobby was
basically that and like [ __ ] like I come
from like watching on the spawn stuff
back in two thousand six seven eight and
like that's when that was like that was
like God like you thinking out it's so
try because twitch and everything exists
and like that's basically like everyone
does it but like it was so unique but I
had a community to fellow community I
don't think there's been a community or
if there is a community I'm not tapped
into it like i used to be i don't think
many of us are so kind of like building
it from the ground up again in like a
really interesting way so we're going to
engage in like I've talked to Cynthia
Corey Cynthia's our long-suffering
community manager here who's like
already topping me back into like the
right forms and whatnot like on the site
and like we're all those communities are
where we can go tap into existing little
pockets and then really just like get
the stuff fun like i want to skype
people on a show i just want like like
some user who's been around for like
years who's like worked in some other
who's like you know in a middle of
goddamn nowhere like skype them in and
ask them what the [ __ ] they think about
like the review for god I don't know
XCOM 2 or whatever you know that's
that's really like break it down and I
think that's what's interesting is like
right now we don't know exactly what it
is because you've got about a month to
make it but we're getting there like
already we figured out okay where it's
going to be a podcast as well so like do
we bring these into the into the set
next door do with that I think Andy
wants that not there you go yeah we got
lots of stuff like that so we're working
on it we've got lots of ideas that's
kind of the basic shape of it of them
when a may change may not change but let
us know in the comments on this ad Jenna
adanya Dwyer at 8a Andy Barron even like
my hearty get in let us know what you
think of of what this show should be in
2016 yeah I'm [ __ ] excited anyway
we're here to talk about video games hmm
it's been a couple weeks